talk a bit about the daddy issues like
did she not have any kind of
relationship with her father was he not
around when she was growing up was he a
furniture like what was the deal there
well she made him out to be a piece of
furniture
and again i i would later have we we'd
later reconnect with him and i can tell
you a little bit about that but uh
he came so she when she was two she's
got a brother her brother's
uh her brother's four years older than
her but
her father left the marriage when she
was two he came out of the closet
when she was two and he moved away and
she would obviously describe him as a
deadbeat dad didn't provide any support
so for so on um and so
but the funny thing is she had a good
relationship
with her father up until her first
marriage collapsed
so she did tell me um as i did dig into
it a little bit that her
her now openly gay father
you know the marriage was over she was
two years old
um he took in her ex-husband
now she had she took in her ex-husband i
said why would your why would your
father do that to you
and her story back to me was well he's
gay and he was attracted to him
so so her dad took in
her ex-husband when they got divorced to
what live with him or
yeah he lived with him he lived were
they friends or was he trying to convert
him to the other team or something
no he had a life flight he had a
lifelong he had a lifelong partner
um and uh he moved in with him in
florida her father
moved away to tampa florida and he moved
in with him in florida
and believe it or not after after her
third gift revelation to me i started
cross-checking
everything and i looked up property
records down in florida
hillsboro hillsborough county and i
discovered indeed yeah he
was on he was on the title for the home
that he had lived with he
lived with her father and his father's
partner and some woman who i
never heard a thing about so that piece
was true
but but again she had a great
relationship with her father
up until um her marriage collapsed
so what other red flags popped up that
um
you know that you saw in the chapter
when you were going through my book i
think it was the daddy issues and the
fact that uh the fact that she
you know initially when i met her i you
know i met her while playing in a slow
pitch softball league
and i didn't think twice about her for
three months you know because it did
concern me a little bit
you know call it judgmental call it what
you will at the age of 26 but i
i decided she'd been married before i
don't want to go down that path
and i bumped into her in a bar and then
we reconnected and
you know things you know things move
forward from there
so yeah we we had dated for about a year
and a half
uh and then got engaged and then uh
married and then you know our first
the first gift my son billy arrived you
know about a year
after we had been married so you quickly
settle into you know raising a child and
there's another child let me ask you
this question when
when you guys were dating for the year
and a half before you get married um
how did she respond to stress in the
relationship like did you guys ever
fight over anything or
no we we didn't and that's that's that's
the thing that uh
completely caught me off guard you know
we we were happily married for
for 17 years 17 years eh
yeah yeah
you